[Música]
bienvenidos a kobe 19 la semana en
américa el espacio de france 24 en que
hacemos un resumen de las noticias más
destacadas
relacionadas con la pandemia de kobe 19
a continuación algunos de los temas que
vamos a tener en esta edición
hablaremos de la decisión de las
autoridades de mexico de brasil y de
eeuu los tres países más golpeados por
la pandemia el joven 19 nuestro
continente que ya determinaron el fin de
la fase pandémica y transitan hacia la
fase endémica veremos lo que esto
significa con nuestros corresponsales
vamos a ver entonces en detalle cómo
está la situación en países como méxico
ecuador paraguay y perú algunos
decretaron como lo decíamos el fin del
uso de las mascarillas también el fin de
la emergencia sanitaria y también de la
fase pandémica veremos cuál es el
balance general que hacen las
autoridades de estos países y en nuestra
habitual consulta con el doctor pérez
hablaremos de diferentes temas entre
ellos la tos crónica una de las secuelas
más comunes que deja el kobe largo y ya
que estamos hablando del fin de la fase
pandémica
nos va a explicar exactamente qué
significa y cuáles son las fases que
siguen todo esto en nuestro camino hacia
terminar por completo la paternidad de
kobe 19 comenzamos y lo hacemos como es
habitual con cifras vamos a actualizar
entonces algunos datos relevantes vamos
a ver en esta oportunidad cifras
globales del avance de la pandemia
comenzamos entonces con el total de los
casos de kobe 19 desde que comenzó la
emergencia a nivel global hasta el día
de hoy hasta el momento entonces
contabilizamos más de 512 millones
542 mil 971 casos registrados los
fallecidos a nivel mundial superan los 6
millones 232 mil 189 y el número de
dosis de vacunas suministradas son más
de 11 mil 345 millones 173 mil 879 dosis
de algunas de las vacunas
un momento para nuestra habitual
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo y asesor
científico de france 24 a quien
saludamos en esta oportunidad desde la
feria internacional del libro de bogotá
al doctor pérez está allí precisamente
para la presentación de su libro
relacionado con la pandemia de kobe 19
doctor pérez muchas gracias por estar
con nosotros y quiero que comencemos
haciendo un poco de pedagogía
explicándole a la gente algo de los
términos que estamos usando en las
últimas semanas qué significa el fin de
la fase pandémica
recordemos que santiago que la pandemia
es lo único que puede decir y ponerle
fin es realmente la o ms que fue la que
lo declaró porque la pandemia es algo
global lo que pasa es que las regiones
pueden pasar de una fase pandémica a una
fase endémica y eso sí se hace
regionalmente pero la pandemia como tal
no ha finalizado algunos países con la
liberación de las restricciones lo que
están impidiendo eso lo que está
permitiendo es pasar a una fase distinta
de la fase pandémica a la fase endémica
de la enfermedad
doctor qué significa entonces para esos
países que han dado por terminada esa
fase pandémica que ya incluso han
levantado el uso de las mascarillas o
han levantado algunas de las
restricciones que sigue entonces para
esos países en esta lucha con la
pandemia porque como usted dice pues la
pandemia todavía no ha terminado
sí igualmente tenemos todavía un déficit
una acción necesitamos seguir
incrementando la vacunación el hecho de
liberar los tapabocas no invita nada más
sino que se está haciendo una fase
distinta en la fase de prolongación de
la inmunización y hay que mantener las
medidas como la higiene como la
monitorización y la detección temprana
de la tasa de casos para darle
tratamiento aquí es muy importante que
la liberación de los tapabocas o el de
escalamiento el uso de tapabocas no
significa el fin de la pandemia ni
quiere decir que la enfermedad sea menos
grave simplemente que menos transmisión
y que hay mayor gente vacuna pero todos
nos debemos vacunar y esto es un digamos
un paso positivo que tengamos que
escalar el uso de tapabocas pero estamos
lejos de finalizar la pandemia como tal
doctor en recientes investigaciones la
inmunidad de las células t que ya no se
explicará qué significa esto fue
efectiva contra la variante o micro
aunque se volvió la de mayor
predominancia en casi todos los países
del mundo en cerca del 90% de las
personas vacunadas qué significa esto
para la humanidad en esta lucha contra
la contra kobe bless y 9
muy importante recordar que hay dos
tipos de inmunidad una inmunidad que es
producida por anticuerpos este mundial'
que se produce por anticuerpos es una
inmunidad que se genera por las células
de las células que son muy importantes
porque las células de guardan también
memoria es decir que después de un
tiempo pasado meses o incluso años
vuelve a recordar el antígeno es decir
el coronavirus y pueden volverlo a
atacar lo que se encontró es que estas
células éste que producen este tipo de
inmunidad que se llama celular y algunas
inmunidades que son de memoria con la
vacunación son capaces de neutralizar
también en este tipo micro y eso ha
hecho que las campañas de vacunación
hayan sido efectivas y hayan podido
controlar la diseminación de esta
enfermedad por ella en países donde hay
baja tasa de vacunación o las personas
no vacunadas pues van a ser susceptibles
pero después que estamos vacunadas
tenemos las dos inmunidad es tanto el
inmunidad o moral por anticuerpos como
ésta que es muy importante que la célula
que perdura más en el tiempo doctor pasó
a preguntarle ahora por nuestra pequeña
sección de 'el hobbit' largo y aquí dejo
un poco mi papel de periodista y le
cuento un poco mi caso personal hace dos
meses para decir comí 19 y ahora
padezco tos crónica como consecuencia de
haber tenido el coronavirus que estudios
hay en torno a lo que genera esto en la
parte de pulmones o de la faringe o de
las cuerdas vocales que genera esta tos
crónica que muchas personas están
padeciendo es incluso una de las
secuelas de mayor cantidad de casos en
pacientes que han tenido kobe 19
sí sí santiago recordemos que lo que
hemos hablado en estas semanas el poder
prolongado hoy largo afecta a todos los
órganos que se han inflamado corazón
cerebro riñón pulmón incluso el sistema
genitourinario pero obviamente el pulmón
es el más significativo porque este es
un conteo respiratorio
hemos encontrado diferentes problemas en
las personas con el 'hobbit' hay una
cosa que se llama tos residual post
inflamatoria después de una inflamación
del pulmón tiene un periodo de tos
persistente alteración del manejo de
secreciones que paulatina mejor
paulatinamente va mejorando pero los
pacientes cuando tienen un poquito más
severo o incluso cuando llegan a la
ventilación mecánica ya tienen un daño
pulmonar que hace que no solamente no
solamente sea la tos sino requerimientos
de oxígeno es decir que en el pulmón
tenemos un gran desafío pero recordar
que estas dos residuales también son muy
probablemente no son prolongadas en el
tiempo durarán unas semanas pero no son
digamos un fenómeno crónico pero las
personas que tienen un daño podemos
dejar por la ventilación mecánica si van
a producirse a largo plazo doctor pues
esperemos que así sea y que está todos
ya me deje tranquilo en las próximas
semanas muchas gracias por esta consulta
doctor y muchos éxitos allí en la feria
del libro de bogotá
las desigualdades estructurales que
sufre la región de américa latina'
dispararon la letalidad del cob y 19 el
último informe de amnistía internacional
revela que las inequidades sociales y
económicas así como los bajos gastos en
protección social y salud pública
agravaron la pandemia de kobe 19 en
nuestra región veamos
las desigualdades estructurales en
américa latina y caribe tierra fértil
para la pandemia así lo revela el
reciente informe de amnistía
internacional que expone como las
inequidades que sufre la región
dispararon la letalidad del cob y 19 las
crisis preexistentes la falta de
infraestructura de inversión pública la
falta de priorizar el ejercicio
fundamental del derecho a la salud
durante décadas generó una tierra fértil
para que la pandemia de kobe 19 pues
llegara y afectará de manera
desproporcional a los países de américa
latina y el caribe la región
latinoamericana con el 28% de los
fallecimientos mundiales se convirtió en
el epicentro de la enfermedad según el
reporte que analizó los datos de 17
países el bajo gasto público en
protección social y sanidad pública por
parte de los estados incrementaron estas
cifras e impactaron directamente las
economías y vidas de los grupos
poblacionales más vulnerables siendo las
mujeres y los menores uno de los más
golpeados con el incremento de 16
millones de personas en pobreza extrema
44 millones de personas padeciendo
inseguridad alimentaria 21 millones de
ellos con inseguridad alimentaria severa
y el 30 por ciento de la población sin
acceso a salud pública este análisis
desde la perspectiva de derechos humanos
permite concluir que la desigualdad
socioeconómica de la región no es
meramente una consecuencia no deseada
sino el resultado concreto de acciones
discriminatorias e inequitativas además
de omisiones de los gobiernos de la
región una alarma que también expuso
recientemente la cepal señalando que el
desigual reparto de la riqueza conspira
contra la recuperación y contra el
desarrollo de la región por ello los
organismos de derechos están a los
gobiernos a tomar medidas efectivas y
una mayor inversión del gasto público
para paliar estas injusticias
a continuación les presento el número de
dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes veamos cómo están las cifras
vamos a comenzar entonces de norte hacia
el sur comenzamos en belice allí han
sido inoculadas 11,12 dosis de refuerzo
por cada 100 habitantes en la república
dominicana en el caribe unas 21 23 dosis
por cada 100 habitantes pasamos a guyana
en américa del sur en donde han sido
inoculadas
774 dosis de vacunas por cada 100
habitantes estamos hablando de dosis de
refuerzo en surinam las dosis alcanzan
ya las 8 18 por cada 100 habitantes y
vamos a finalizar en argentina en donde
han sido suministradas
45,11 dosis de refuerzo por cada 100
habitantes
vamos a ir ahora hasta perú en países
donde hubo varias noticias a lo largo de
la semana hubo escándalos y hubo también
varios anuncios por parte de las
autoridades sanitarias por eso
conectamos el lema con francisco
zacarías francisco gracias por
acompañarnos y comencemos con ese
escándalo en cuanto a la cuarta dosis de
vacunación porque el colegio médico de
perú denunció que el personal médico
recibió más dosis de lo normal y esto
desencadenó problemas de salud
precisamente en los médicos
hola santiago el escándalo estalló
cuando personal medico inmunizado así
como algunos adultos mayores tras
recibir la cuarta dosis de la vacuna
contra el kobe 19 reportaron sufrir
efectos desfavorables como malestar
general cefaleas diarreas vómitos entre
otras dolencias pero qué fue lo que
ocurrió según las denuncias el
ministerio de salud desde el país les
aplicó el doble del refuerzo de la
vacuna moderna los médicos denuncian que
en lugar de inocular les 50 microgramos
de la dosis les inyectaron 100
microgramos que produjo más reacciones
adversas a lo normal el ministerio de
salud mediante un confuso comunicado
afirmó que no hubo ningún error y que
todo está dentro de los protocolos
establecidos pero el colegio médico de
perú señala que las recomendaciones de
la fed ya que la agencia de alimentos y
medicamentos de los eeuu indica que para
la cuarta dosis sólo se debe utilizar 50
microgramos del producto el colegio
médico acusó que fueron sorprendidos por
las autoridades sanitarias porque las
dosis que se aplicaron
lo que ellos pensaban la defensoría del
pueblo por su parte reveló que 1.500
médicos vacunados se reportaron efectos
adversos por eso inició una
investigación y exigió que los hechos
sean esclarecidos y se establezcan las
responsabilidades
este escándalo ha provocado una caída en
el avance de la vacunación según algunos
expertos quienes exigen al ministerio de
salud admitir que hubo un error y
aclarar la situación para recuperar la
confianza de la población entre quienes
también se encuentran el personal de
salud
francisco han levantado algunas de las
restricciones allí en perú la más
reciente tiene que ver con los niños de
hasta 5 años que van a poder ingresar a
estadios y coliseos si tienen las dos
dosis de la vacuna que es como el
protocolo completo de la vacunación
básica que más dicen las autoridades
dentro de las nuevas disposiciones que
establecen las autoridades de este país
los niños mayores de 5 años ya pueden
ingresar a los coliseos y estadios solos
y presentan su carnet de vacunación que
acredite haber recibido en territorio
peruano o en el extranjero la primera y
segunda dosis de la vacuna contra el
kobe 19
esto les devuelve a los menores la
libertad para acceder a los partidos de
fútbol y demás espectáculos están de
esparcimiento el gobierno atendió las
recomendaciones de los expertos que
reportaron casos de trastorno de
conducta de menores durante la pandemia
los especialistas advirtieron que el
aislamiento habría acentuado conductas
negativas en niños y adolescentes el
estudio les permitió detectar que uno de
cada tres niñas niños y adolescentes
estaría en riesgo de sufrir el problema
de salud mental es por eso que la nueva
disposición también incluye a menores
hasta los 17 años la norma aclara que
sólo para los lugares cerrados como
cines y centros comerciales es
obligatorio el uso de una mascarilla acá
n95 o una mascarilla quirúrgica de 3 y
encima de esta un tapabocas de tela
francisco y seguimos hablando de
anuncios porque el ministerio de salud
decretó alerta epidemiológica en
diferentes regiones del país por brotes
de influenza h3n2 y también por el
incremento de casos de dengue y de
malaria cómo está la situación
las autoridades peruanas lanzaron la
alerta epidemiológica de la influenza
ah3n2
desde finales de 2021 hasta el 15 de
abril el instituto nacional de salud
registró 169 contagiados con el virus 38
por ciento de casos se encuentran en la
región ayacucho le sigue la región piura
con 31% mientras que en lima se halló 22
casos en una escuela del ejército donde
falleció un cadete de primer año la
influenza ah3n2 es una infección viral
que ataca la nariz garganta los
bronquios y eventualmente los pulmones
los grupos más vulnerables a sufrir
complicaciones son embarazadas menores
de 59 meses ancianos y pacientes con
enfermedades crónicas en perú como todo
su sistema sanitario ha estado enfocado
a entender la pandemia del coi 19 ha
habido un descuido de otras enfermedades
ajenas al coronavirus el centro nacional
de epidemiología
prevención y control de enfermedades
alertó que los casos de dengue hasta
fines de marzo de este año se
incrementaron a más del 50% registrado
el 2021 la malaria se extiende hasta
inicios de abril al 35% del total
contabilizado el año pasado mientras que
los contagiados por la enfermedad de
manos pies y boca se incrementaron en
más de 40% en sólo dos semanas diversos
expertos recomiendan al gobierno de
pedro castillo no descuidar las
afecciones crónicas como diabetes cáncer
y vih además de dotarles de mayor
presupuesto al sector para la prevención
diagnóstico tratamiento y control de
enfermedades
francisco muchas gracias por este
completo informe desde la ciudad de lima
vamos a cambiar de tema porque los tres
países más golpeados por el kobe 19 en
nuestro continente ven hoy la luz al
final del túnel eeuu dijo que estaba
fuera de la fase pandémica méxico dice
que está transitando hacia un estado
endémico y brasil puso fin a la
emergencia sanitaria pero a pesar de las
buenas noticias las autoridades
aclararon que estas medidas no
significan que el virus ya se haya ido
veamos
eeuu el país más golpeado por el cob y
19 en el mundo está hoy fuera de la fase
pandémica así lo aseguró el principal
asesor médico de la casa blanca- anthony
fauci durante una entrevista con pbs
newshour no tenemos 900.000 nuevas
infecciones por día y decenas y decenas
y decenas de miles de hospitalizaciones
y miles de muertes estamos en un nivel
bajo en ese momento entonces si decimos
estamos fuera de la fase de la pandemia
en este país lo estamos esto según fauci
significa que ya no hay una infección
generalizada que se propaga rápidamente
pero que el virus sigue presente justo
un día antes fue su vecino méxico el que
dio por finalizada la atención
prioritaria a la pandemia de kobe 19 de
acuerdo con los parámetros de la
organización mundial de la salud la
situación actual de mexico con respecto
al kobe 19 permite considerar el cierre
del ciclo epidémico para transitar al
estado endémico de la enfermedad la
medida obedece a una reducción en las
hospitalizaciones y los contagios por el
virus además de una alta tasa de
vacunación brasil que fue el epicentro
de la pandemia en américa latina anunció
a mediados de abril el fin de la
emergencia sanitaria gracias a mejoras
de escenario de mi orgullo gracias a la
mejora del escenario epidemiológico a la
amplia cobertura de la vacunación y a la
capacidad de asistencia de salud tenemos
hoy condiciones de anunciar el fin de la
emergencia de salud pública de
importancia nacional esta medida sin
embargo no significa el fin del cómic 19
continuaremos conviviendo con él
continuaremos a kobe de virus el estado
de emergencia había permitido tomar
medidas excepcionales en un país cuyo
gobierno ha sido fuertemente cuestionado
por el manejo de la crisis sanitaria con
una significativa disminución en el
número de muertes y casos positivos
otros países del continente se mueven a
flexibilizar aún más las medidas
sanitarias colombia por ejemplo dirá
adiós al uso de la mascarilla en
espacios cerrados a partir del primero
de mayo
pasamos ahora hasta ecuador para ver
cuáles son las novedades a lo largo de
esta semana en ese país suramericano
gustavo ortega nuestro corresponsal
france24 en la ciudad de quito nos
cuenta cómo va allí la situación gustavo
buenas tardes gracias por acompañarnos y
fue levantada allí la medida del uso de
la mascarilla a partir de cuándo y
cuáles son las restricciones que siguen
allí impuestas por el gobierno
hola que tal un saludo efectivamente el
gobierno ecuatoriano anunció que ya no
será obligatorio del uso de las
mascarillas en espacios abiertos y
cerrados inclusive los ecuatorianos
vuelven a verse las caras sin
mascarillas luego de 26 meses pnd en el
país andino los ciudadanos programa
guardarse de sus bolsillos y retomar la
normalidad como exhortó el presidente
ecuatoriano guillermo lasso se
levantaron más de 200 restricciones
sanitarias aseguró el primer mandatario
ante el más reciente informe
epidemiológico que da cuenta de una
positividad del 5 por ciento del país
según cifras oficiales el ejecutivo
asegura que le ha ganado la batalla al
cob y 19 luego de un plan de vacunación
que le ha costado mil millones de
dólares al país con vacunas mayormente
provenientes de china los eeuu canadá y
chile aseguró el gobierno nacional 87
por ciento de la población de más de 3
años ha sido vacunada con una dosis y el
83 por ciento cuenta con dos dosis
mientras que 35 por ciento de las
personas ya poseen las dosis de
refuerzos y se avanza con las cuartas
dosis según cifras oficiales el ecuador
mantiene los mejores indicadores
sanitarios de la región y una de cada
diez camas de hospitalización atienden
pacientes de kobe 19
gustavo según las autoridades
ecuatorianas algunas regiones de este
país ya estarían totalmente libres de
kobe 19 qué más dicen
si la pandemia ha generado 27 millones
de personas fallecidas en américa latina
según el anuncio del gobierno nacional y
en ecuador' la reducción del índice de
letalidad se mantiene en 0,09 por ciento
con relación al año pasado las últimas
cuatro semanas los índices de
positividad se mantienen a la baja
mientras que la demanda de camas de
hospitalización y cuidados incentivos se
reduce constantemente según el ejecutivo
nacional récord se encuentra en una fase
de transición a indicadores endémicos y
por ello exhortó a no relajarse y
continuar con la vacunación en la última
semana de pandemia se contabilizan mil
73 personas confirmadas con kobe 19 una
reducción de contagios en comparación a
la semana 3 de la pandemia donde se
contabilizaron 52 mil casos según la
titular de salud héctor se mantiene por
cuarta semana con un índice de
positividad del 5 por ciento en el país
hasta la fecha existen 85 personas
hospitalizadas de 28 en unidades de
cuidados intensivos según datos
oficiales en la mayoría de las
provincias no hay muertes por comí 19 y
el sistema de salud vuelve a la
normalidad en este país
ahora quiero que dejemos el tema del
contagio de los fallecidos y de la
situación y hablemos de la economía cómo
está avanzando la reactivación económica
en ecuador gustavo
si el gobierno ecuatoriano ha calificado
esta fase de la pandemia de reactivación
al 100% luego de avanzar en la
reapertura de fronteras la reactivación
de los aeropuertos mayor conectividad
aérea y el país opuesto a la
reactivación económica y social y sobre
todo el turismo extranjero que se
incrementó en 20 por ciento en
comparación con el año 2021 según cifras
oficiales además estaban utilizando los
feriados nacionales para intentar
reactivar económicamente al país el
banco mundial ha proyectado que ecuador
crecerá 4.3 por ciento en año 2022 el
producto interno bruto también crecerá
3% de 2023 según el organismo
multilateral en un informe publicado el
pasado 7 abril en este informe se
sostiene que las economías de américa
latina del caribe van camino a una
recuperación tras la pandemia 19 aunque
las secuelas de la crisis sanitaria
persisten pero en medio de los anuncios
de crecimiento económico y la
eliminación del uso de las mascarillas
las movilizaciones con el día del
trabajador en el país estarán a la orden
del día a propósito de las marchas por
el primero de mayo organizaciones
sociales y trabajadores anunciaron
protestas confirmando la participación
de los trabajadores indígenas educadores
y médicos que saldrán a las calles a
exigir
de todas las autoridades inclusive
aseguran que no existen planes
económicos concretos y el gobierno se ha
estancado en una crisis política con la
asamblea nacional y recientemente la
renuncia de cuatro ministros en las
últimas horas se activará un plan de
seguridad para las movilizaciones del
primero de mayo a pocos días de
cumplirse el primer año de la
administración el presidente guillermo
lasso gustamos muchas gracias por este
completo informe desde la ciudad de
quito la capital ecuatoriana según un
estudio realizado por la organización a
world in that a la desigualdad a la hora
de distribuir las vacunas a nivel
mundial sigue siendo alarmante esto ha
dificultado obviamente superar la crisis
sanitaria a nivel mundial
la desigualdad en el acceso a las
vacunas contra el joven 19 y la
disminución de pruebas para detectar el
virus han afectado los servicios de
inmunización rutinaria en muchos países
africanos
esto hace que cada vez estemos más
ciegos a los patrones de transmisión y
evaluación de este virus no va a
desaparecer solo porque los países dejen
de buscarlo sigue propagándose sigue
cambiando y sigue matando del changing
and its tell killing
debido a la interrupción en la
vacunación algunos países en la región
registraron entre enero y marzo de este
año cerca de 17.500 casos de sarampión
una enfermedad muy infecciosa y en
algunos casos mortal lo que supone un
aumento del 400 por ciento respecto al
mismo período del año pasado
por otro lado 24 países declararon
brotes de una variante de polio durante
2021 una cifra que multiplica por cuatro
el número de países que lo hicieron en
2020 además al menos 13 naciones
africanas registraron nuevos brotes de
fiebre amarilla en 2021 por encima de
las 9 2020 y las 3 de 2019
orts también durante el fin de semana
las autoridades sanitarias de la
república democrática del congo
declararon un brote de ébola bola
achacan que hoy se ha confirmado un
segundo caso en un familiar del primer
paciente lamentablemente ambos pacientes
han fallecido dos expresiones update sin
embargo las autoridades sanitarias
también señalan la falta de disposición
de los ciudadanos para inocularse como
un problema para la lucha contra el cob
y en efecto consideran que los países
deben mejorar sus técnicas para incitar
a la población a hacerlo we have seen al
psn de after orden chiíes
hemos visto que después de más de dos
años existe cansancio por la pandemia y
la vacunación y por eso las autoridades
deben estudiar cómo reforzar los
programas de vacunación
programs and be the strangers a costa
vaccination porque la vacunación es y
seguirá siendo un componente clave para
reducir el impacto del cob y 19 en el
futuro knight chino center future algo
que ya procedieron a ser panamá y costa
rica ambos países relanzaron el pasado
viernes la semana de vacunación de las
américas con un evento en la frontera
común con el objetivo de inmunizar a las
personas que no tienen acceso a regular
a los servicios de salud incluyendo
personas indígenas inmigrantes según la
organización panamericana de la salud
qué novedades tuvo méxico a lo largo de
esta semana nos conectamos con mario'
carbonell nuestro corresponsal en la
capital mexicana para conocer más
detalles -mario gracias por acompañarnos
en el programa y comienzo por
preguntarle por ese decreto del gobierno
de poner fin a la fase pandémica en
mexico cuál es el balance
así es se ha declarado ya el fin de este
ciclo epidémico y en el balance que
hacen las propias autoridades consideran
que ha habido un manejo positivo un buen
manejo de la epidemia puesto que al
inicio se declaró esta jornada de sana
distancia que es el distanciamiento
social que les permitió ganar tiempo
para reconvertir hospitales para
habilitar unidades kobe y para prolongar
los tiempos de contagio de las cuatro
horas que ha habido sin duda la segunda
ha sido la más agresiva la de la
variante delta que es la que ha
provocado la mayor cantidad de muertes
hoy en día la cifra global
oficialmente reconocida de fallecidos es
de más de 320.000 no obstante bueno pues
los cálculos extraoficiales son aún más
elevados el subsecretario de salud hugo
lópez gatell ha dicho que hoy en día el
promedio diario de fallecimientos es de
sólo 4
los casos son menos de 300 la capacidad
hospitalaria es de 98 por ciento para
pacientes kobe de ahí que se pueda
hablar de este tránsito a la fase
endémica maría también fue retirado ya
el mandato del uso de la mascarilla como
han vivido los mexicanos estos primeros
días sin tener que usar la mascarilla
cubriendo parte de su cara
en cuanto al uso del cubrebocas el
gobierno ha dicho que no va a declarar
como tal el fin de la obligatoriedad de
usar el cubrebocas a nivel federal
puesto que nunca se impuso como tal
algunos gobiernos estatales si lo
impusieron como una norma obligatoria y
ya lo han estado retirando hoy en día el
subsecretario lópez gatell dice
textualmente que su uso ya no es
imprescindible lo que bueno ha provocado
algunas reacciones de especialistas en
el sentido de que aún es necesario
portar la mascarilla sobre todo en
lugares cerrados con poca ventilación lo
cierto es que en las calles uno puede
apreciar que poco a poco la gente sobre
todo en espacios abiertos ha comenzado
ya a dejar el cubrebocas que había sido
hay que decirlo ya como una práctica
habitual la gente se había acostumbrado
o la mayoría de la gente al uso de
cubrebocas así se veía en las calles y
pues hoy en día ya la mayoría de los
estados están declarando que su uso es
pues a voluntad propia
méxico este fue un país que tuvo muchos
problemas mario para poder dar marcha a
los planes de vacunación quiero
preguntarle precisamente cómo está
avanzando los niveles de vacunación en
este país ahora que han liberado algunas
de las restricciones y los ciudadanos
pueden llevar una vida un poco más
tranquila
de acuerdo con la autoridad sanitaria la
cobertura de vacunación general en la
población adulta es del 90% se está
aplicando ya en las dosis de refuerzo
desde hace tiempo en cuanto a estas
dosis de refuerzo en la cobertura de 56%
estos estamos hablando de unos 46
millones de mexicanos que ya tienen un
esquema de tercera dosis incluso ya está
aplicando la cuarta se ha abierto ya el
registro para los menores de 12 años en
adelante para que también reciban la
vacuna no así los niños de menos de 12
años a menos que estén amparados y esto
sigue siendo un tema controvertido de
que no hay autorización aún para los
pequeños para ser vacunados la mayoría
de la gente ha acudido a estos macro
centros de vacunación y hoy en día el
canciller marcelo ebrard ha dicho que se
priorizará la compra de vacunas
elaboradas en américa latina' ese será
el objetivo ahora en cuanto a la
vacunación
-mario muchas gracias por este reporte
desde ciudad de méxico nos vamos ahora
hasta el continente asiático porque en
beijing la capital de china un nuevo
brote de casos de la variante omicron ha
hecho temer que se ha impuesto allí en
la capital un bloqueo muy parecido al
que está viviendo shanghai en este
momento miren solamente el martes las
autoridades registraron 33 nuevos casos
de contagio de kobe 19 así está la
situación
vuelven las largas filas para hacerse
pruebas pcr en beijing algunas partes de
la ciudad se transformaron en lugares
dedicados a realizar pruebas masivas en
un intento de contener un nuevo brote de
omicron el distrito de chaoyang de
beijing registra actualmente el mayor
número de casos
estoy preocupada sobre todo porque
trabajo en el distrito de chaoyang así
que me preocupa que pase algo allí el
despliegue de las pruebas masivas ha
despertado el temor de que se produzca
un cierre al estilo de shanghai
en la mayor ciudad de china 25 millones
de residentes han sido confinados en sus
casas durante semanas con un acceso
impredecible a los alimentos ante el
temor de correr la misma suerte los
residentes de beijing se están
abasteciendo
aunque el número de nuevos contagios
sigue siendo relativamente bajo en la
ciudad las autoridades dos se arriesgan
y se aferran a la estrategia de kobe
cero pues todos los nuevos casos se han
puesto bajo control la capital se
encuentra actualmente en una fase
crítica de prevención en control de la
pandemia
beijing reportó 33 nuevos contagios del
martes una cifra mínima comparada con la
de shanghai donde se registraron 16.000
nuevos casos y 52 nuevas muertes
vamos a volver a nuestro continente
vamos a hablar ahora de paraguay vamos a
conocer cómo está la situación allí en
asunción se encuentra nuestro
corresponsable fernando box ya para
darnos más detalles fernando bienvenido
al programa cuál es el balance que hacen
allí las autoridades en paraguay desde
que levantaron el decreto de la
emergencia sanitaria que se traduce esto
para los paraguayos
los números ministeriales es lo que
indican que paraguay ha atravesado su
tercera ola de contagios de kobe 19 y
actualmente registra la menor cantidad
de casos activos desde el inicio de la
pandemia esto ha significado un relajo
importante para un sistema de salud
pública que ha sido completamente
colapsado durante los peores momentos de
la crisis sanitaria que significó la
llegada de coronavirus es en este
contexto que se enmarca la decisión del
gobierno de levantar la emergencia
sanitaria desde hace dos semanas el
poder ejecutivo ha decidido levantar
todas las medidas que estaban vigentes
desde marzo 2020 cuando se detectó el
primer caso de por navidad'
quizás la medida más importante que ha
sido levantada ahora es el uso
obligatorio de tapabocas en lugares
públicos que ahora queda como una mera
recomendación del gobierno del
presidente mario abdo benítez fernando
justamente quiero preguntarle por esa
normativa que ya terminó ya los
paraguayos pueden hacer un uso de las
mascarillas dependiendo de su criterio y
qué restricciones entonces se mantienen
en este país americana
la eliminación del uso obligatorio al
tapabocas proyecto con mucho optimismo
por parte de los sectores más golpeados
por la pandemia comprende los eventos
por el sector gastronómico que ve en
este posible adiós a los tapabocas una
luz de esperanza hacia una reactivación
económica en contrapartida a otros
gremios como el de los trabajadores de
la salud si tienen exhortando a la
población que mantengan sus tapabocas y
el resto de las clases y tareas para
evitar cualquier tipo de la nueva ola de
contagios o contagios de otros virus
respiratorios el propio ministerio de
salud sigue recomendando las mascarillas
en lugares cerrados en hospitales en el
transporte público y sobre todo en los
colegios sobre este último punto el
ministerio de educación dispuso un nuevo
protocolo sanitario en todas las
escuelas del país para que estudiantes y
docentes tengan en todos momentos
disponibles mascarillas en caso de ser
necesarias además este nuevo protocolo
favorece como nunca antes las
actividades al aire libre en todos los
cuentos las escuelas y colegios del país
fernando quiero terminar con la
vacunación paraguay fue uno de los
países que más dificultades tuvo para a
adquirir las vacunas y presenta uno de
los índices más bajos del continente en
cuanto a la vacunación cómo está
avanzando
paraguay sigue siendo uno de los países
con menor tasa de vacunación contra el
coronavirus en todo el continente
actualmente poco menos del 50 por ciento
de su población total de 7 millones
habitantes tiene al menos dos dosis de
la vacuna uno de los motivos de este
bajo índice son las dificultades
iniciales que tuvo el país para acceder
a la vacuna principalmente por el
incumplimiento del calendario acordado
con el mecanismo kóvacs de hecho
actualmente el gobierno paraguayo está
en tratativas para recibir este contrato
debido al incumplimiento que fue
catalogado por autoridades sanitarias
como una perversión de las personas a
cargo del mecanismo kóvacs según este
contrato
paraguay debía recibir más de 4.200.000
dosis la vacuna pero sólo arribar a un
poco más de un millón no obstante ante
la baja cantidad de gente dispuesta a
vacunarse hoy en día el gobierno tiene
la capacidad la cantidad suficiente de
vacunas para seguir con su campaña de
vacunación que ya contempla una cuarta
dosis para ciertos sectores de la
sociedad como el personal de salud
personas mayores de 50 y personas
inmunodeprimidas
fernando gracias por este reporte desde
asunción y finalizamos hablando de la
feria de cruceros seatrade cruise global
una de las más grandes de su tipo que
tiene lugar en la ciudad de miami en
eeuu y tal parece que el pronóstico de
cara a la reactivación económica en el
sector del turismo para el continente
americano es muy alentador veamos
un futuro extremadamente brillante y
ecológico para la industria de cruceros
un sector duramente golpeado por el cob
y 19 así lo pronosticó que el y cree que
recibiendo de la asociación
internacional de líneas de cruceros en
la conferencia ha sido el cluj global en
miami beach antes de la pandemia este
sector estaba en auge sin embargo en
2020 el número de pasajeros embarcados
en todo el mundo fue de 5,8 millones un
81 por ciento menos que en 2019 algo que
causó pérdidas millonarias bueno estaba
muy expectante porque prácticamente con
la pandemia la industria turística la
industria los cruceros se vio muy
golpeada y venimos con muchas ganas para
desarrollar el turismo para
desarrollarlo porque cuando el turista
llegue a chile en un crucero también se
baja a la tierra y
pernocta y algunas veces consume
importante el impacto muy importante se
espera que los volúmenes de pasajeros en
cruceros se recuperen un 12% por encima
de los niveles previos a la pandemia
para fines de 2026 en aras de lograrlo
muchas oficinas gubernamentales de
promoción turística de países del
continente americano están centrando su
estrategia en tradiciones culturales así
como en paisajes naturales y abiertos es
decir lo opuesto al encierro que
representó la pandemia chile ha optado
por promocionar rutas enológicas
argentinas su patrimonio arquitectónico
méxico las llamadas rutas del café y el
banano mientras que países como colombia
panamá costa rica y república dominicana
se inclinan por promover el caribe que
sigue siendo el principal destino dentro
de este sector aunque también exploran
otros puntos en latitudes apartadas del
trópico que tenemos
143 pedidos de cruceros para llegar a
montevideo
un número importante también a punta del
este en general llegan 60-70 al año por
eso le decimos que baje nunca estamos
abiertos en esta tierra solidaria a
recibir a todos los turistas que vengan
de cualquier parte del mundo entretanto
sitio el club móvil anunció que miami
albergará en mayo de 2023 la primera
edición del evento food and beverage
dedicado a la gastronomía en cruceros
hasta aquí con 19 la semana en américa
nos vemos la próxima semana
[Música]